ein neues duo an der spitze janine
wissler und susanne hennig welt so
sollen die linkspartei im
bundestagswahljahr einen schritt nach
vorn beim testen städte die kostenlose
corona schnelltests anbieten verweisen
auf ihre erfolge und jubel bei der
heim-wm in oberstdorf und sich karl
geiger silber beim springen von der
normalschanze
die nachrichten nicht anders heute mit
christian sievers ich begrüße sie ganz
herzlich bei uns guten abend in allen
kristin otto ist hier für den sport
nachher in der sendung in einer
viertelstunde konnte die umfragewerte
verbessern und klären wohin die partei
eigentlich will
das sind die beiden großen
herausforderungen für das neue
führungsduo bei der linkspartei nach
ihrer wahl auf einem online parteitag
haben sie an die partei appelliert mehr
selbstbewusstsein und geschlossenheit zu
zeigen
und das ist die neue führungsspitze der
linken die 39 jährige janine wissler
kommt aus hessen ist dort vorsitzende
der linken-fraktion im landtag
die 43 jährige susanne hennig welt so
ist aktuell landes und
fraktionsvorsitzende in thüringen die
wahl der beiden frauen muss noch per
briefwahl bestätigt werden der advent
ihn berichtet seit mai noch die blumen
nach oben nehmen fürs foto folgen sie
noch der regieanweisung ab jetzt aber
sollen sie in ihrer partei den ton
angeben susanne hennig welt so und
janine wissler
nach neun jahren lösen sie das
führungsduo kipping riexinger ab wissler
warnt heute vor sozialer spaltung und
vor zu vielen politischen kompromissen
heute und morgen konkrete reformen
durchsetzen
aber wir wollen auch die gesellschaft
grundsätzlich verändern unsere vision
das ist der demokratische sozialismus
ohne ausbeutung von mensch und natur
hennig welzow fraktionsvorsitzenden
thüringen gilt dagegen als pragmatikerin
in thüringen regiert die linke schon
dasselbe will sie auch für den bund
schwarz grün kommt oder rot rot grün
liegt auch an uns sind wir bereit dafür
zu streiten dass es eine
mindestsicherung gibt die namen verträgt
sind wir bereit dafür für ein
öffentliches konzessionssystem auf die
straßen zu gehen im parlament zu kämpfen
aber auch in einer regierung
ich sage ja wir sind es und dann müssen
wir es auch in einer konsequenz tun
ein großes koalitions hindernis ist die
außenpolitik der bundestagsabgeordnete
matthias höhn fordert dass die linke
hier auf die anderen parteien zugehen er
will etwa eine europäische armee und
blauhelmeinsätze unterstützen bei der
wahl zum partei-vize feld höhen durch
die linke ist nicht der nabel der welt
die zustände ändern sich gesellschaft
verändert sich und ich finde darauf
haben wir zu reagieren
wissler wird mit 84,2 hennig welt so mit
70,5 prozent gewählt gemessen werden sie
am ergebnis der bundestagswahl im
aktuellen politbarometer liegt die linke
bei sieben prozent bundestagswahl ist
doch unser stichwort accola banerjee in
berlin gibt es denn jetzt ein bisschen
mehr klarheit bei der großen frage ob
und unter welchen bedingungen sich die
linke an einer bundesregierung
beteiligen würde ist auf den ersten
blick sieht es zumindest aus als ob die
neue parteispitze einigermaßen
harmonisch den willen zum mitregieren
signalisieren möchte aber auf den
zweiten blick zeigt sich dann doch dass
die sache noch nicht ganz ausgemacht ist
man hat es in den reden von hennig weser
und janine wissler gehört da gibt es
durchaus noch unterschiede
janine wissler hat neben dem sozialen
demokratischen sozialismus zum beispiel
auch die änderung der
eigentumsverhältnisse genannt das ist
ein stichwort das richtung linker flügel
der partei geht während
ich will so eben sehr klar gemacht hat
dass man pragmatisch sein möchte und das
ziel
grün rot rot sei und man hat eben auch
an der wahl zum partei-vize gesehen
über 50 prozent der delegierten wollten
nicht dass dort ein mann mit bestimmt
der zumindest über auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr reden will und da offenbaren
sich eben die alten grabenkämpfe die
noch nicht beigelegt sind die
doppelspitze teilt sich jetzt wie üblich
die rollen hennig will so für mehr
regierungsfähigkeit janine wissler um
die linke bei der stange zu halten
beide müssten das jetzt in irgendeiner
form relativ schnell klären damit die
parteien den wahlkampf gehen kann
vielen dank nach berlin die neue
doppelspitze der linkspartei porträts
von janine wissler und susanne hennig
welt so gibt es online bei zdf heute und
in unserer zdf heute gesundheitsminister
jens spahn hat einen tag bevor er ende
oktober sein positives corona
testergebnis er hielt an einem privaten
abendessen mit mehreren menschen
teilgenommen
weitere details dazu hat sein
abgeordnetenbüro jetzt bestätigt demnach
traf sich der minister mit etwa 12
unternehmern die damals gültigen coroner
regeln seien nach angaben des gastgebers
eingehalten wurden
vor dem treffen hatte spahn im zdf die
menschen gemahnt beim feiern und bei
veranstaltungen vorsichtig zu sein jetzt
zu unserem nächsten thema heute abend es
war ein fall im herz 2018 der große
wellen geschlagen hat der mord an dem
saudischen journalisten jamal k schoggi
ein us-geheimdienst bericht macht jetzt
den kronprinzen von saudi arabien
mohammed salman persönlich dafür
verantwortlich und bringt gleichzeitig
den neuen us-präsidenten in eine
zwickmühle
er lebte in den usa und veröffentlichte
dort kolumnen mit kritik am saudischen
königshaus 2018 verschwand er beim
besuch des saudischen konsulats in
istanbul
nach wochenlangen dementis gab saudi
arabien zuckerschock ii sei bei einer
aus dem ruder gelaufenen
geheimdienstaktion ermordet worden
eine version die die usa so nicht
glauben tom pollock
das also ist der bericht des us
geheimdienstes der bestätigt dass der
saudische kronprinz den mord an jamal k
die angeordnet hat mohammed bin sei man
habe den einsatz gewaltsame mittel
unterstützt er habe katar die als
bedrohung für das königreich empfunden
us präsident joe biden des nun
einreisebeschränkungen gegen 76 saudis
verhängen
im interview mit einem
spanischsprachigen us sender erklärt er
ich habe gestern mit dem könig
gesprochen nicht mit dem prinzen
ich habe ihm klar gemacht dass die
regeln sich ändern wie werden sie
verantwortlich machen für die
missachtung von menschenrechten
doch der kronprinz selbst wird nicht
bestraft dafür gibt es kritik aus der
eigenen partei und von menschenrechtlern
die einzige botschaft die hier an die
diktatoren in die region gesendet wird
ist ihr seid immun gegen jegliche
verantwortlichkeit
ich bin nicht zufrieden dass der prinz
nicht zur verantwortung gezogen wird er
hat das angeordnete amt wusste davon
auch heute wird der kronprinz nicht zur
rechenschaft gezogen
denn donald trump ihn bericht unter
verschluss und stets an seiner
unterstützung zum königshaus in riad
fest zum angekündigten kurswechsel joe
biden gehört nun dass er geplant
waffenlieferungen an saudi arabien
gestoppt hat dass die usa aber
ausgerechnet den auftraggeber für den
mord verschonen zeigt dass beide nicht
bereit ist jeden preis zu zahlen
tatsächlich kann joe biden auf die
allianz mit den saudis nicht verzichten
im nahen osten wo auch andere staaten
wie iran oder russland das geschehen
mitbestimmen bleibt das königreich ein
besonders wichtiger bio strategischer
partner
ob die us-sanktionen doch einfluss haben
auf das politische schicksal des
kronprinzen ist momentan offen
riad jedenfalls reagiert empört auf den
us bericht er sei falsch und
inakzeptabel
und wir bleiben noch im moment in den
usa hat das repräsentantenhaus einem 1,9
billionen dollar schweren
konjunkturpaket zugestimmt
damit will us präsident joe biden die
korona krise abfedern
der senat muss jetzt auch noch zustimmen
und in den usa steht ein weiterer
impfstoff vor der notfall zulassung der
von johnson & johnson
experten der us arzneimittelbehörde
haben die anwendung des präparats jetzt
empfohlen
in der eu wird mit einer zulassung für
mitte märz gerechnet
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf die korona
situation bei uns in deutschland das
robert koch institut meldet dass die
sieben tage ins events wieder leicht
gestiegen ist und zwar auf 63,8 9762
menschen haben sich binnen 24 stunden
neu infiziert das sind 598 mehr als
vergangenen samstag große hoffnungen
liegen auf den schnelltests immer mehr
städte wollen nicht länger auf den bund
warten und bieten selbst kostenlose
tests an elisabeth schmid gerade zum
wochenende hin ist hier große andrang im
testzentrum in osnabrück mit dem auto zu
fuß oder mit dem fahrrad geht es zum
kostenlosen antigen schnelltest
kleinkinder zuhause hat 5000 tests in
zwei wochen der stadt dauerte das hin
und her zwischen bund und ländern bei
den kostenlosen schnelltests zu langen
erstes fazit in osnabrück wurden
dutzende positive fälle erkannt keiner
davon zeigte vorher symptome aus meiner
sicht kann das ein instrument sein
frühere öffnung hin zu bekommen denn
jeder der sich testen lässt weist für
den tag dass er zumindest an diesem tag
nicht infektiös ist ein negatives
testergebnis und dann ins kino oder in
die kneipe
die hoffnung ist groß doch schnelltests
erkennen in der regel nur vier von fünf
positiven fällen erklären epidemiologen
jemand der so an der grenze ist
vielleicht so wo sich eine infektion
gerade entwickelt die werden dann oft
übersehen und zum beispiel bei kindern
und jugendlichen ist es im augenblick
scheinbar so dass sie noch schlechter
positive infektion erkennen schnell test
sein trotzdem besser als gar keine tests
in apotheken und arztpraxen wo abstriche
bald bundesweit kostenlos durchgeführt
werden sollen ist allerdings noch vieles
unklar wo können die tests abgenommen
werden wie werden die tests genau
abgenommen und auch noch nicht genau
geklärt was passiert bei positiven tests
wird an testzentren weitergeleitet wird
an die ärzte weitergeleitet die stadt
osnabrück bleibt dem bund weiter voraus
und bietet neben kost
loosen schnelltests demnächst auch gut
30.000 selbsttests gratis für den
hausgebrauch an
für lehrer etwa oder erzieher 369 das
ist heute die zahl der cholera-toten in
deutschland 369 neue todesfälle an einem
tag seit dem beginn dieser virus krise
sind laut robert-koch-institut 69 1888
menschen an oder mit cupid 19 gestorben
fast 70.000 schicksale
familienangehörige freunde kollegen aus
dem leben gerissen so viele
hinterbliebene die trauern
überall in deutschland gab es heute
gedenkgottesdienste der katholischen
kirche mehr dazu von marion geiger
während draußen die menschen fürs
wochenende einkaufen eine zeit des
innehaltens in mainzer dom
bischof peter kohl graf hat eingeladen
zum gedenkgottesdienst für die opfer der
korona pandemie er will den menschen mut
machen den betroffenen bei stehen die
trauernden und hoch belasteten stärken
gemeinschaft ist wichtig und fehlt
gemeinschaft fehlt sehr stark wir haben
das auch gemerkt wir haben auch im
bistum wahrgenommen dass wir noch
stärker werden müssen etwa in sozialen
angeboten
der bischof sieht eine große müdigkeit
der menschen er hat betroffene aus
unterschiedlichen bereichen eingeladen
um gemeinsamkeit herzustellen die viele
in dieser zeit so schmerzlich vermissen
ich finde es ein schönes signal von der
hirsche dass man gerade diesen tagen
versucht dann alle möglichen menschen
berufsgruppen und betroffenen zu denken
für mich war es ein schönes zeichen
gutes signal
all das was wir im alltag im moment zu
erleben an belastungen an problemen an
krisen hier mitnehmen zu können und auch
einen ort zu haben wo man das mal
ablegen darf oder lassen darf der rat
der europäischen bischofskonferenzen
hatte dazu aufgerufen an die opfer der
korona pandemie zu erinnern
viele katholische bistümer in
deutschland gedenken heute der toten und
der menschen die korona besonders hart
getroffen hat sie sollen unterstützung
erfahren der psychologischen nutzen ist
vor allen dingen das erleben von
wertschätzung der gesellschaft und damit
auch trost spenden durch die
gesellschaft und das vermitteln von
gemeinsamkeit dass ich damit nicht
alleine bin
innehalten im pandemischen alltag ist
zeigt auch die opfer sind nicht
vergessen jetzt noch frankreich das land
fährt eine ganz andere anti corona
strategie als deutschland in frankreich
sind schulen und geschäfte seit monaten
offen um das virus trotzdem im griff zu
halten gilt landesweit eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre
ergebnis die inzidenz war zwar hoch aber
einigermaßen stabil
doch jetzt ist sie über die 200er marke
geschossen
zwei besonders betroffene regionen
ziehen die notbremse rund um nizza etwa
darf man ab heute ohne triftigen grund
am wochenende nicht mehr vor die tür an
arbeit so leer sind die strände selten
an der côte d'azur netzverkehr zurück
zum strengen lockdown macht zum dritten
mal dicht zumindest am wochenende für
die tägliche erlaubte stunde frischluft
braucht man nun wieder ein formular
geübtes prozedere eigentlich die leute
werden nachlässiger aber wir zeigen
keine toleranz kassieren 135 euro
bußgeld denn die inzidenz liegt den
nutzer inzwischen bei mehr als 700 vor
allem die englische variante treibt die
zahlen in die höhe und die intensiv
ärzte an den rand der erschöpfung
ebenfalls stark betroffen der großraum
paris mit seinen armen wohngebieten
nördlich der metropole keine region
verzeichnet so viele corona tote
innerhalb eines jahres haben wir es hier
nicht geschafft mehr intensivbetten und
mehr personal bereitzustellen
die verantwortlichen haben es versäumt
wichtige entscheidungen zu treffen auch
lokale behörden wie hier in paris
kritisieren die zentralregierung wollen
eigenständig maßnahmen beschließen
denn tausende drängen sich seit tagen am
sonnigen seehofer
die leute nehmen das nicht mehr ernst
kaum einer drag maske ich glaube leider
wenn wir sehen was in anderen städten
gerade passiert dass wir hier in einer
woche auch einen lock down haben werden
instrument in paris wie in weiteren
debatte muss mit hohen infektionszahlen
heißt es noch abwarten und beobachten
ende nächster woche will die regierung
über mögliche verschärfungen entscheiden
so jetzt sind wir in dieser sendung an
diesem samstag beim sport bei christie
und endlich jubel und große
erleichterung am dritten wettkampftag
durch die erste medaille für die
deutschen bei den nordischen
ski-weltmeisterschaften in oberstdorf
skispringer karl geiger gewinnt von der
normalschanze silber
das ist der moment als karl geiger
sicher ist eine medaille zu haben nur
welche wird es werden kurz zuvor legt er
nach 103 eineinhalb metern mit 102 im
zweiten durchgang die grundlage um die
konkurrenz unter druck zu setzen
der japaner kobayashi und der slowene
lange shack können geiger nicht von der
spitze verdrängen so ist das quad
schüler der führende nach dem ersten
durchgang der über gold und silber
entscheiden kann der pole behält die
nerven und gewinnt gold geiger mit
silber und der ersten wm medaille für
den deutschen skiverband
denn omega-3 wird dritter zweimal einen
guten sprung erwischt und bin richtig
froh dass mir das so gelungen ist weil
es hätte auch ganz anders ausgehen
können und so schön klingt der gold
jubel des weltmeisters über
und einen überraschenden erfolg gab es
im skicross durch florian bild von der
in georgischen bakuriani seinen ersten
weltcup sieg verbuchte der 25-jährige
starnberger erstmals ganz oben nach
spektakulärem rennen in dem er hier noch
auf rang drei liegt dann aber eine
dieser typischen skicross stürzte der
kanadier fliegt raus wilmsmann bleibt
verschont und kann am schweden moberg
vorbeiziehen emotionen bin einfach nur
glücklich natürlich das tor
untergebracht zu haben was sie ganz ohne
viel gearbeitet habe seine freude
ungetrübt den olympiasieger lee man
übersteht diesen sturz ohne nennenswerte
blessuren wintersport auch im aktuellen
sportstudio zu gast 23 uhr der weltbeste
bobpilot francesco friedrich und
anschieber torsten marx dazu natürlich
alles zur fußball bundesliga da brodelt
es bei schlusslicht schalke 04 mächtig
einige führungsspieler sollen die
ablösung von trainer christian gross
fordern die vereinsspitze dementiert ist
hier eine angebliche revolte und die
hohe niederlage in stuttgart mit 15
verschärft die brisante lage bei den
königsblauen am 23 spieltag bisher nur
heimsiege die bayern souverän 5 1 gegen
köln wolfsburg hertha 20 dortmund
bielefeld 3 0 das topspiel leipzig
gladbach ausführlich im sportstudio
gestern stoppte bremens frankfurts
erfolgswelle morgen noch drei spiele
die bayern bauen ihre spitzenposition
vorläufig auf fünf punkte vorsprung aus
den kann leipzig wieder auf zwei
verringern
wolfsburg dritter nun mit drei punkten
abstand auf frankfurter dortmund
vorläufig verbessert auf 5 und stuttgart
vorerst raus aus der unteren hälfte
dort kann sich noch einiges verschieben
ab köln alle mit niederlagen so hat
mainz morgen die chance auf einen
nichtabstiegsplatz zu rücken
tja heimvorteil nutzen klingt ganz
einfach klingt ist sie vielen dank
so jetzt noch ein großartiger fund bei
ausgrabungen in pompeji ein wagen der es
in sich hat die archäologen sind
begeistert so etwas haben sie bisher
noch nie gefunden
der triumph fragen ist sehr gut erhalten
er war vor etwa 2000 jahren
unter asche und lava begraben worden und
er bietet überraschende details an den
seiten verzieren ihnen nicht etwa
schlacht und kriegsszenen sondern
erotische darstellungen frauen und
männer beim liebesspiel italiens
kulturminister sagt pompei versetzt uns
weiterhin mit seinen entdeckungen ins
erstaunen frische temperaturen mit ein
bisschen sonne hat katja ohne vergleich
im angebot für den sonntagmorgen für
heute empfehle ich ihnen das heute
journal mit der kollegin marietta slomka
um 22 45
wir sind auch morgen wieder für sie da
aber erst wünsche ich ihnen allen einen
sehr angenehmen abend